is it even more confusing to you than
the rest of us when you hear like
stories like John Jones for example
who's like he just can't get his [ __ ]
together like he can't stop [ __ ] and
doing drugs and I don't care about the
drugs and all that stuff because listen
that's just part of life not that I'd do
it but I'm just doing it's just yeah
yeah but the steroids thing that pisses
me off because listen we're gonna you
know cage was another guy and you're
looking to hurt the other guy and to go
in there basically with a weapon that
the other guy can't see and it's not
allowed to use that's that's not cool
yeah even though you're hurting each
other like you have to trust the guy
that you're across the cage from oh yeah
and and and everyone's like oh you know
he's he's a he's such a freak you know
look at him Baba but then the day is he
a freak or is he a guy who was on
steroids for his whole career we don't
know I mean if I was on steroids I
guarantee you guys would think I'm a
freak even though I'm a freak even
without it but I'd be even more of a
freak
yeah it messes up the game the details
too are weird like like Jesse Taylor
who's a guy who kind of who uh who was I
think in uh on the Ultimate Fighter
house and he was like doing very very
well and I think he won or he came in he
got drunk and he [ __ ] up and Dana
wouldn't let him for he was gonna fight
in the finals and Dana yanked him
because he was causing a big problem
so he comes back and he's about the
about to fight again or he fights again
and then they test positive for
something it was a dick pill and said
the dick pills are I think I'm saying
there's a Jesse Taylor Josh it was okay
so viagra not viagra no an
over-the-counter one but how are these
viagra actually truly have stuff that
you could fail for do you know I don't
know but some of the organic might it's
the gas station to take pills painted
great no one in a while you think
nominal you think the dick pill thing is
[ __ ] I don't I'm gonna say I don't
think that guys aren't using Victor
pills because I know plenty of guys do
I would never but oh yes you would but I
don't think that's why they're failing I
think they're using that as a cover-up I
know John Jones had used that as a cover
up once and now I think he probably has
another cover for it because he failed
again but I
Geisel again these supplements they find
after they fail they find they have
their management other team you know
find out supplements that could possibly
be tainted oh I was taking this okay 7sm
and now look oh it was tainted so that's
what yeah I mean we can't say he wasn't
taking this because it's something you
could get somewhere caused enough doubt
into the thing even though you didn't
disclose it even as one of your
supplements you know that's that's the
other thing if you did take a dick pill
you should disclose it right because I
know fighters who've taken that and they
get drug tested and they don't fail John
Jones was lying about it the first time
because yeah obviously was lying about a
bunch of stuff that he but how could he
be so silly this is the thing with joy
like the test he was an in competition
test I mean it was like right around the
time like like if you took it then it
wouldn't even have helped you and he
knows how they test like why the [ __ ]
would he have done it's just insanity
well was it at it was after the fight he
failed of the day of the fight I I think
the the second favorite year was this
most recent water right after the fight
was right after I don't know man I I
just don't I don't I don't know I feel
like there's some guys who have a
doctor's and they like take them off
things and the manage your blood somehow
and their urine and know exactly when
they're gonna pass or fail and know
maybe a miscalculation I don't know okay
it's crazy is it tempting at all I mean
I know you don't do it but is it a
tempting thing like [ __ ] man I'm tired I
should I should do something or do you
just like it's is it just not even a
thought that would crush it is it first
of all I for me I got I got a
five-year-old boy gun you know I got
kids and I don't want to ever wake up
and have to explain to them that you
know the dad cheated because they're
gonna be hearing from their kids their
friends in school right like why it was
okay for me to cheat but they're not
about a cheap I don't want that's like
one of the biggest things at this point
it was always like you know I don't want
to I don't want to cheat you know I
don't want to cheat these other guys I'm
hoping that I'm cheating and I want to I
don't want to I don't want to do it do
that but then it becomes all somes like
you know I don't want to let my kids
down my family down so you do think of
that I don't have kids so big kids
actually kind of come into your
mentality that's definitely I don't want
to let them down I look like a good guy
yeah I mean when you yeah when you have
a kid it's like all of a sudden you
there is a responsibility for your
actions that wasn't there before
somebody's watching everything that you
do not necessarily in a negative way
it's just there's a personal
responsibility not just to raise the kid
but to do things that you would tell the
kid to do and not do things
that you would not have the kid do right
yeah and then also like if they were
gonna if if there's drug testing I just
don't I wish they could figure out a way
to where you can't take these steroids
because obviously guys are still doing
it and if they're gonna let people take
steroids the thing that sucks about that
obviously then I would do it if
everybody's doing steroids then but the
problem is they're not good for you like
you're literally gonna you possibly die
early and all this crap and then the
guys are gonna take several ways to a
whole nother level some of these guys
before the USANA were just jacked out of
control don't you get tits if you come
off them too like that like I know kind
of blockers they are but if you come off
and then don't you get like breasts
because uh like like that like they they
they the testosterone blocker or
whatever it is you have to get the
estrogen blockers as you're coming off
of them I think oh that's why when
people get like popped for estrogen
block I think getting rocked got popped
for an estrogen blocker yep - I thought
it was Chiana that nothing share some
baseball players yeah I know that's like
a thing you don't want breasts because
they come off to the South Shore and
they don't like yeah bring that estrogen
estrogen back down I don't know anything
about that stuff I obviously I've been I
always thought like should I take a
little uh a little gym blocker guys
everything you're taking steroids I've
thought of it but not being a big but
just kid I'm always so tired my sleep
socks oh you want to come that's an
animal all he does is [ __ ] come
that's a savage guy like that to me he
lives an ideal life
he's a happily married guy he likes to
have sex he likes to fight